man bien encadré la question du viol sur
mineure c'est ce à quoi on tenté de
répondre ce matin les sénateurs de la
délégation aux droits des femmes et le
consensus est clair contrairement aux
députés le sénat s'opposent à la
possibilité de requalification du viol
sur mineure en délit dans le cas où les
circonstances du consentement sont
difficiles à prouver
nous considérons unanimement que le viol
est un crime et que on ne souhaite
absolument pas et on n'approuve pas
c'est même pas une histoire de sous et
on désapprouve totalement le fait de
dire que c'est un délit
on est désolé le viol est un crime et il
faut le maintenir comme un crime
autre point sur lequel le consensus
devrait être trouvé au sénat
la question de l'âge ainsi une relation
sexuelle entre un adulte et un enfant de
moins de 13 ans devrait systématiquement
être qualifié de violent sans avoir
besoin de démontrer la violence la
contrainte la menace ou la surprise
moment donné je me disais que c'était
peut-être quinze ans sauf que m 15 ans
et porter un jugement moral sur des
relations entre jeunes au collège et au
lycée
hors la loi ne doit pas être là pour
porter un jugement moral sur les
relations sexuelles des jeunes et des
adolescents
il faut absolument instaurer ce seuil de
13 ans
ce que nous voulons c'est qu'il n'y ait
plus d'interrogations sur le
consentement d'un enfant a une relation
sexuelle avec un adulte et nous
considérons qu en dessous de 13 ans
c'est un enfant et que notre devoir est
de protéger le consensus entre
l'assemblée le sénat et le gouvernement
sur ce point est loin d'être trouvé
al'inverse l'allongement du délai de
prescription de 20 à 30 ans pour un viol
sur mineure recueilli un avis quasi
unanime